[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday february 3rd
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor
on the show
sue grey's 12 page update was released
this week and while boris johnson got
through it in terms of the chamber
performance a trickle of letters have
been going in
so
what happens next i'll speak to james
forsythe and i'll also be joined by
michael potillo
the winter olympics start on friday but
there won't be the familiar crowds of
supporters china is still doggedly
pursuing a zero covert strategy when
will it unlock i'll speak to cinder and
charles parton
the threat of russian invasion of
ukraine still looms
in his columnist week douglas murray
says he's concerned about britain's
ambassador in kiev he'll be on to
explain why
to finish
could kamala harris be heading to the
supreme court
freddie gray and kate andrews will join
me to discuss
before we get going the spectator is
delighted that canaccord genuity wealth
management are sponsoring the week in 60
minutes
canaccord are experienced wealth
planners and investment managers who go
above and beyond to offer you support
and guidance you can visit at
candywealth.com to find out more
remember to subscribe also to our
youtube channel click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
you will never miss an episode again if
you tap the bell icon
the sioux grey update is out and boris
johnson remains under pressure
thanks to the met police and
investigations into number 10 parties
the full report won't be released for
some time to come
there's still though a trickle of number
10 confidence letters going into the
1922 chairman graham brady so what
happens next i'm joined now by our
political editor james forsyth
james so we've had the sue grey report
update in um the handful of pages it was
and i think ahead of that report coming
in there was a sense that all the juicy
bits would be taken out so there
wouldn't be such a crunch moment for
boris johnson but yet it does feel a
little bit jumpy in the comments this
week what's going on
yes it does katie i mean we are back
once more so people are going to firstly
pop it up to the fourth floor of port
culler's house to see whether you can
see people going on trying to find their
way to graham brady's office or not
now i mean there are several reasons for
this i think one of them is something
that boris johnson said in the chamber
on monday in response that jimmy savile
drive at kslama has gone down very badly
with tory mps and i guess prompted some
people to kind of put letters in
because they're not prepared to defend
it the other thing is that the update
sue grey is very careful not to call it
a report the update
doesn't make for pretty reading and it
is hard to believe reading it but the
report itself is not going to be
very difficult reading for the
government and hard for it uh to weather
and then finally there's the fact that i
think there was some
lingering hope on the tory benches that
the events being referred to the police
would involve kind of fairly junior
members of staff and could be dismissed
as something that boris johnson could
have couldn't really have known about
his alleged presence at several of them
makes that line of defense far harder
and james i suppose when we're back to
the tasks that we never really want to
get into we're trying to guess the
number of letters in um what's your
sense of where we're at because i think
that we're talking about crunch points
but do you think we can accidentally in
a way get to 54 letters on quite a
random day that no one really saw as a
day for a confidence vote in boris
johnson yeah i think you could because
they're going to trickle his swelling
and beginning to turn into a stream and
i think one of the other things is that
in these one-on-one meetings that boris
johnson is having with mps you know um
and you talk to those who've been there
they talk about how he puts his head on
his hands a lot nods and nods as they're
talking to
to him
and
lots of people take away from that that
he has agreed with them on their point
whether they're saying arguing to cancel
the knicks rise or to scrap that on
energy bills and then when those things
don't happen now boris johnson has been
quite careful not to commit himself to
that happening but the people listening
to him think he has um they then get
irritated and that makes them more
likely to put letters in i mean the
crucial question right now is that for
every publicly declared letter
how many do we think have put one in
privately and there are different
opinions about this in the parliamentary
party and it's and it's hard to work out
because when there's name as prime
minister it was a roughly one-to-one
ratio between publicly declared letters
and and
and
and letters that had actually gone in uh
when i in london smith was leader yeah
uh i think it was about only about a
quarter of the letters writers publicly
owned up to what they'd done now if you
talk to those people on the boris
johnson campaign team they think that a
not unreasonable estimate is that for
every one letter in publicly there are
one and a half letters in privately that
would mean that we are in the 30s in
terms of the number of lesser
submissives now that is obviously not 54
but but it is uh it is worryingly close
to that for downing street considering
this this steady trickle
and james was seeing efforts from boris
johnson and his team to shore up his
position and ultimately remind mps
there's more to life than parties and
stories about birthday cake how is he
getting on with that because we had the
leveling up white paper this week which
had been talked up as you know
a way to reset the premiership
yeah you've had loving art white paper
you've had the energy announcements
today and i mean you know the hope is to
kind of to sort of try and and show some
momentum on domestic policy
and change the conversation i think the
problem and the challenge for the
government is that as this story bubbles
along
it is very hard to get uh the media to
concentrate on anything else and it's
also very hard to persuade the public
but a government that so clearly isn't
in control of itself is in control of
events and i mean that that is one of
the big challenges for the tories right
now
and let's talk about those energy
announcements because ultimately uh
as we expected uh there are issues in
terms of the price cap going up um but
the national insurance
hike is going ahead something lots of
tory mps thought might go because of
boris johnson's weak position
and so
the treasury is offering some support
but does it mean much when actually
working people are going to have their
taxes going up as soon as we get into
the spring
so i think it's worth saying this this
is not nothing this is in terms of what
it will mean for individual households
it's more generous than if you'd
scrapped that on uh domestic fuel bills
um and i think you see two interesting
things here
one is the kind of this kind of smoothie
mechanism that they have come out with
is essentially the state
acting as a kind of um as a kind of
insurer of last resort you know that
they are basically trying to kind of
retrofit an insurance policy for rising
energy prices uh and then the second
thing i think is striking is how far up
the income scale the means test goes uh
the means tested help goes the council
tax rebate you know that goes to four in
five households you know uh band d which
is the top council tax ban which is
eligible to it you know the average
household income in that is fifty
thousand pounds which is uh
which is a considerable amount of money
and so i think you see i think you see
an attempt to kind of widen where the
help is going this is this is this is
not like a warmest home discount which
is aimed largely people on kind of
sixteen thousand pounds a year or less
this is going far further up the income
scale
and finally james what happens if energy
prices don't go down eventually that is
the big risk with this the the
assumption behind the government is
making here is that this rise in energy
prices is essentially a product of the
pandemic and the fact that investment in
projects was delayed uh there was then a
big spike in demand when when when the
world economy was essentially turned
back on again having been turned off and
so prices will come down as more
investment goes in if that doesn't
happen
then this policy isn't going to work and
that that is the big
risk involved in it
thank you james
so that's the latest at the time of
recording
to talk more about what happened in
westminster this week i'm joined now by
michael patello
the former conservative mp and
broadcaster who himself ran for the tory
leadership in 2001.
michael thank you for joining us this
week on spectator tv um as as we speak
to one another uh we're hearing the drip
drip of no confidence letters slowly
trickling in a handful this week
is the situation terminal for boris
johnson
no i don't don't think it is i think his
position has probably improved quite a
lot over the last few weeks
um a combination of circumstances the
opposition to him in the conservative
party is disorganized and divided i
think some of them have been quite
spooked
by some of the tactics of the whips and
some of the things that have been
written about them
i think he was very much helped by the
defection of a tory to the labour
benches
i think he was helped by what david
davis said a couple of weeks ago in the
house of commons because david davis
managed to get the tone of it wrong
but i suppose most of all he's been
helped by the fact that the
sugray report is coming out in trips
and so it's very difficult for a tory mp
who wants to make a decision about
whether to get rid of boris johnson or
not to know quite what when that moment
is
because there's a sense that we ought to
wait until the whole process is
completed well that may now be weeks or
i think more probably months
and there's always the feeling that not
all the information is there yet
and in the interval the alternatives
have been on display rishi sunak liz
trust i'd say a few others
and i've not been overly impressed by
them in the last few weeks i dare say
tory mps haven't been either
so remember they're not just deciding
whether they want to get rid of boris
johnson they're having to think about
who might be a better replacement
after the long and bruising business of
choosing a new leader because if boris
goes there'll be a lengthy leadership
election because the conservative party
procedures
are really not designed for a
conservative party in office and
although they've now been used
repeatedly when the conservative party
is in office but they're inappropriate
for it so one way or another i'm not
saying that boris will survive
but i think his chances of survival are
pretty good and i think they're a good
deal better than they were
and
one of the things that's been dominating
the conversation in westminster in
recent weeks other than cake
is confidence votes it's yet to happen
but as you as you mentioned and we're in
a situation where no one's really
organizing the letters she feels it's
dripping it's various parts of the party
so it's very hard to predict but if we
end up in a situation where 54 letters
go in and there is a confidence vote do
you therefore think boris johnson is
actually quite a strong position to win
that vote or could a secret ballot come
back to bite him
well i'm not in the house of commons
anymore i'm distant from it and you can
only know that if you're in the house
commons and indeed even if you're in the
house commons you can't know that
because you can't know everybody's mind
you don't know what's going to happen
you don't know what can be the impact of
um
a a brief election campaign around the
vote of their confidence you know i
think boris would get in touch with a
lot of members of parliament he would
use his famous charm so there are all
sorts of unpredictable things but with
all those caveats i would have said yes
he has a pretty good chance of surviving
the confidence vote
if theresa may survived the confidence
vote i think boris has a pretty good
chance
and although things have moved on a lot
since the last election
there must be some conservative mps who
remember that they won the last election
with brexit and with boris now brexit
will not be an issue in the next
election or certainly not in the way it
was at the last one and then they have
to ask themselves can they win next time
without either brexit or boris
now you encourage margaret thatcher not
to resign
and i wondered
if you were uh speaking to borrow shots
and that's perhaps that's what you were
just saying there about um what mps
could be thinking or maybe should
consider what do you think boris johnson
should be saying to his mps to make them
focus their minds
well the most important thing is to say
something to them and i mean on a
one-to-one basis
the reason i urge margaret thatcher not
to resign
after all the members of her cabinet had
urged her to quit was that in the brief
leadership election campaign
she had not canvassed a single member of
parliament she hadn't asked a single one
of them to vote for her the campaign was
handled by others or rather mishandled
by others and so my point to her was
she was still in the race at that stage
and i thought that if she canvassed hard
she could still um hold on now i don't
think boris needs this bit of advice
because he's rather good
at canvassing people but the second bit
of advice apart from talking to people
that i would offer him
is something that i gained from michael
hezeltein and hezeltine's principle was
that no member of parliament was a lost
cause was a hopeless case
so even if you know that somebody has
opposed you for decades that's no reason
why you shouldn't go and canvas them
because you don't know
whether that person will calculate that
uh keeping you boris is a better bet
than the alternative
um
as an example of this in a way
i probably spent 20 or 25 years
hoping and even mildly campaigning
that boris should not become the leader
of the conservative party and here i am
now rather believing that if i was still
a conservative member of parliament i'd
probably want to retain him rather than
lose him at the moment
um now you're a low tax story and one of
the things which has been interesting to
follow in the past week or so is boris
john's had lots of meetings with his mps
doing some of the things that you've
just been talking about you know
telling them why
they should stick with him and
repeatedly the national insurance hike
has come up and many mps as i think
tends to happen in a boris johnson
meeting left with the distinct sense
that the prime minister agreed with them
and was going to ditch it but we heard
over the weekend from rishi sunek and
boris johnson that the national
instruments rise is going ahead how much
of a problem do you think is that for
boris johnson's position if tories
ultimately feel that he is
not uh as leading the conservative
government they want to see and perhaps
the next election is going to have
talked about more big state conservatism
than what they would want to
well i think they're going to be very
unhappy that national insurance is going
up um some of them a few brave souls
actually voted against it and the reason
they voted against it was not just they
didn't want tax rises but in particular
they didn't want that tax rise they
didn't want attacks that fell on uh
working people quite heavily
and they didn't want attacks that fell
on jobs quite heavily
and on employers and that could have an
effect on putting up prices
and the combination of all that with the
other things that are going to happen
the general uh inflationary position
and the energy prices it's it's a
serious situation
and
members of parliament are very worried
that they're going to lose
heaps of votes about all of this
the um the comparison with margaret
thatcher is quite interesting
because
she probably for a while at least uh
talked about a game than the one that
she played
i mean i was just checking this today
you know the rate of income tax the top
rate was 60
until 1988.
that is to say that she had been in
office for nine years with the top rate
of tax of 60
top rate of tax today i believe is 45
so
of course it depends what you're
measuring and i believe that it is true
that the tax burden is now at its
highest for 70 years so this is
displeasing to tories
on the other hand if you're going to
make historic comparisons it's probably
best to you know make them quite
accurate and to me i mean it is
extraordinary to recall that we were
there nine years in government with the
top rated tax of 60 percent
so perhaps um boris johnson and russia
soon have a point when they say they
have thatcher rights still
um
i i i i don't i don't think they are
that right but i think rishi
soon at perhaps is being saturated in a
slightly different way
which is he said as chancellor that he
was going to increase spending on
social care and on the national health
service in particular the national
health service and that it would have to
be paid for
uh that there wasn't a magic money tree
well of course there has been a magic
money tree but the the
magic money tree has come to an end
that's his position and for his
credibility as chancellor it would be
very bad i think if now it could be said
oh yes but all these increases can be uh
can be uh paid for
and the taxpayer doesn't need to bother
to recompense this checker it can all go
on borrowing now margaret thatcher was a
bit of a stickler for trying to reduce
public borrowing
and rishi therefore is showing some
thatcherite tendencies in wishing to
control
the amount of public borrowing
now i want to talk about the point you
made earlier which is ultimately one
thing that's keeping boris johnson safe
right now is if we think about who could
replace him no one's really sticking the
head above the pads that you had tom
teugenhat i'm saying he will run if
there's a vacancy um but no one in
cabinet and you uh managed your own
challenge for the leadership of the
party in 2001. what do you think will be
going through the minds of um you know
would-be contenders you mentioned rishi
sunik and liz trust when it comes to
when to make your move how to operate
where why perhaps you look loyal while
also keeping your chances there
well i think they'll be wondering
whether there is any dignified way to
indicate to the world that you'd be
willing to lead the conservative party
whilst also telling the world that you
are absolutely loyal to the existing
prime minister
and the fact is that there is
there is no dignified way of doing that
i think rishi sunak made a pretty good
error right at the beginning of this
when he was very slow to indicate
support for the prime minister and did
so in a pretty half-hearted way on that
first day liz trust was pretty slow but
she's since become
apparently a very fulsome supporter of
boris johnson as leader of the
conservative party no they they are in a
bind um tom tuggenheit is in a much
easier position he can declare his hand
he has declared his hand
the the thing that um tom trigger hat
would have to fear because i've made
both of these mistakes so
one mistake i made was being in the
cabinet and trying to indicate to people
that if john major left i would be ready
to stand but the following time which
was 2001 the one you referred to
um i declared my candidacy very early
because i didn't want a reputation for
hesitancy
and then for a couple of weeks maybe i'm
exaggerating but there were no other
candidates and i was hanging there the
only target so in all that time all the
fire was directed at me so tom is
somewhat in that position uh being a
declared
prospective candidate
he does offer himself as a target for
criticism and for indeed character
assassination because things get pretty
nasty in the tory party
and on that i mean the tory party does
have a reputation for being registered
but some have been querying that
recently and asking about the tory party
has lost its appetite what do you think
well i don't think the tory party
actually has an appetite for regicide
it's just that you know every now and
again it deems it
necessary i mean obviously i wasn't in
agreement when they deemed it necessary
in the case of margaret thatcher
when they deemed it necessary in the
case of theresa may i thought it was
massively overdue
but uh the decision i think i may have
said this already
is not of course just whether you want
boris johnson or not but whether you
think that someone else would do better
i think it's a very tricky decision
because
things look pretty bad at the moment
it's difficult to imagine with the anger
that people feel about partygate
that they'll have forgotten it in three
years time
but three years time is a very very long
time i think it is quite possible
that at least they won't feel the rage
that they feel now well maybe
maybe they'll maybe they'll have turned
against boris and they won't turn back
but you can't rule anything out because
when the electors go to the polls
presumably the choice is going to be
boris johnson or kia stammer
and i think the chances of boris beating
kierstarma are still pretty good so
these are complex calculations that
conservative members of parliament have
to make
maybe boris's greatest fear should be
the following that quite a lot of
members of parliament don't have much
experience
not only because they came in in 2019
but they've not been in a collegiate
situation for most of that time because
of covid
so they're they're quite they're quite
uh raw they're quite immature i mean for
example i hear people talking about how
bad the local election results are going
to be and how terrifying that is but it
isn't because the local election results
are normally terrible for the government
and very often governments have done
extremely well afterwards i i remember
meeting boris johnson to interview him
the day after the european elections of
oh my goodness what was it 20
2019 wasn't it when um the conservatives
had come fifth and got nine percent
but later that year six months later
would win a general election with a
majority of 80.
so you know the electorate make
decisions about how to vote and
understand perfectly well
they know that a local election is quite
different from a general election and
they may well vote very differently i i
think on the other hand
if i've seen the the latest polls which
put labour five points ahead
i mean five points ahead it is
historically quite a small margin for
the opposition party when the government
has been through a rough patch which it
certainly has
and do you think in order for boris
johnson to
keep support of those mps who decided to
stick with him for the time being does
he need to change how he governs because
one of the big frustrations is the fact
that numbers head often seems very
dysfunctional and that leads to bad
choices and new terms
well of course he ought to change the
way he governs i mean i i think the
shambles at downing street is absolutely
disgraceful
and and unrecognizable from anything
i've ever seen
in the past
so of course he ought to govern better
and he ought to reorganize
he ought to become more serious as a
person he ought to become more
interested in understanding the
decisions that he takes and not for
example in the case of partygate
thinking that because he didn't much
like the decision that he had announced
that probably one way of showing his his
contempt for his own announcement was to
ignore the rules that he was imposing on
others
so of course there ought to be
improvements but when i heard him say in
the house of commons uh i've got it and
i'll fix it
that to me was wholly incredible and i
think will be to the vast majority of
conservatives so of course he ought to
change but i very much doubt whether any
of them is placing a bet on the
likelihood that he will change
and just finally um michael gove is your
biographer he wrote that you were the
future of the right and i think in turn
you once said that he was the future of
the right um do you still think that
uh i doubt it i mean it
no one's talking about michael gove at
the moment as a future leader which of
course might turn out to be to his
advantage
what what i do know about michael gove
is that he is um in many ways an
absolutely model minister
uh you know he he stands out
head and shoulders above most of his
colleagues because when he gets to a
department he has an idea about what he
wants to do
and he gets it done
so you know i think he's a very very
strong
candidate for prime minister
unfortunately he's made many enemies
along the way and so i don't anticipate
that that will be what will happen but
in terms of ability uh michael
probably would be
um the strongest candidate
i remember that's not all that tory mp
is worried about they're also worried
about who can win elections
so boris's
inability to be
certainly a conventional i would even
say an effective prime minister
is
for some members of parliament at least
secondary to his proven ability to win
one election after another
if he can keep his ratings uh going the
right direction i suppose turn those
ratings around um thank you very much
for joining us today michael
thank you katie
beijing's winter olympics start tomorrow
but don't expect cheering crowds or
packed out stadiums in this week's cover
piece cindy writes about how china found
itself in a zero cover trap to explain
cindy joins me now along with charles
parton a former diplomat who is now a
senior associate fellow at rusi
cindy in this week's magazine you write
about how china has got stuck in a
zero-covered trap to begin can you just
tell
viewers what exactly the current rules
in china are
so obviously the country is massive i
think people often forget that it's
bigger than europe as a continent so
given that there's quite a lot of
different rules flying around depending
on the cover situation in each region or
city um in the worst case scenario
over christmas in the city of xi'an in
central china people weren't even
allowed to leave their flats to go food
shopping so for the first time ever the
government delivered food rations now
that's to a city of 13 million people
and you can imagine the kind of problems
that arise from that kind of logistical
challenge so that was on the harsher end
of things normally in china lockdown
looks like you've got
in your flats you've got food deliveries
going on through the gig economy and you
can go out shopping every other day also
when you're not in lockdown people have
a health code on their or their mobile
phones where it's a traffic light system
and if you're green you can go into all
sorts of public spaces if you're amble
or red because you've recently been
somewhere high risk then that limits
your movements now that app during more
relaxed times in china oh you know it's
more it's merely a formality people
don't really check it too much but at
the moment where delta and omicron are
both flaring in the country it's not a
relaxed time at all so we're seeing a
lot of tension at the moment
and cindy we also have the winter
olympics and you write in your cover
piece about the director and what the
choice tells us
yeah so the director is jon emol who is
one of my favorites and the reason
probably he caters to my taste is
because i'm someone more of a foreigner
to chinese taste these days he has films
such as hiro or razer the red lantern
you know they're more popular at film
festivals like cannon sundance than they
are within china but that was a
deliberate choice this opening ceremony
as it was in 2008 are both designed to
appeal to the foreigner if they're
designed to have international appeal to
show china off but the difference
between this time in 2008 is that that
was you know an event watched by two
billion people around the world 91 000
live audience members this time round
node members of the general public will
be at the winter olympics only a select
few people like putin imran khan who
leads pakistan uh dr tedros of the wha
and some well-connected chinese will be
allowed to be there and that's because
of covert so it's a completely different
atmosphere where even though china wants
to show itself off to the world um zero
covert and and the flare-ups are just
simply casting a shadow over everything
charles how important are events such as
these um to china events like the winter
olympics in terms of geopolitics
i think they're the parties regardless
is extremely important that's why it
puts so much money and effort both into
getting the games in the first place and
then putting on a wonderful show as a
demonstration that china is now a strong
country and cindy when it comes to the
zero code approach um
why are we now in a situation where
there is still a zero code approach
because we hear stats about eighty-five
percent being jabbed uh
if you look at other countries that is
the case that you would expect there to
be enough vaccine covered to ease things
up a bit yeah absolutely i mean almost
your china is almost at herd immunity
but i think omicron is the thing that
changes everything because
as we know from from the western
experience omicron does escape a lot of
the original vaccines that we have with
the exception of maybe pfizer modena the
mrna vaccines now china's vaccination
program very impressive has only been
based on the chinese ones which are
based on this called so-called
inactivated vaccine technology so what
used to be you know dead viruses and
then they're injected to create an
immune response and not nearly as
effective as mrna vaccines so given less
efficacy um even that kind of coverage
is not enough to save china from omicron
if xerokovid wasn't there as a first
barrier as it were um added to that
china's also politically boxed itself in
because the government has made it you
know part of a political legacy to save
lives you know i've got quotes in my
piece where presidency is saying that
because we are socialist country we
value human life in a way that western
capitalist individualist
individualistic countries don't so
you've made it they've made it into a
political situation so now to you 10 and
say oh we're going to have to live with
covert that's going to be a very hard
pill to swallow for the public who've
who've brought that narrative and then i
think you also have to think about the
chinese society's own hypochondria which
is um you know they've always been
health obsessed
and so people are terrified of the virus
um not least because of this confluence
or factors because politics has come
into it but that means that there's no
clamor to open up either within china
and leaving diaspora like me in london
rather desperate to go back but not
really being able to
charles are you surprised that china has
been um followed in i suppose russia's
step with their sputnik vaccine which
seems very similar and i've been
reporting it to uh vaccines in the west
um it feels as though china is perhaps a
step behind
well china deliberately turned down the
offer to manufacture in its own uh
territory uh western vaccines which are
effective uh and that's why i think it's
it's part of the reason why it's landed
itself in such an appalling dilemma i
mean if you go back and look at the very
start of the crisis uh the communist
party was on very much on the back foot
and the people were very very unhappy um
but they recovered pretty quickly i mean
they recovered at the expense of course
of the of of the the overseas position
because the sort of propaganda that they
were putting out which was aimed
incidentally
as indeed as a large part of the
olympics at the domestic audience it
recovered the domestic audience because
the message was aren't we doing well
look at us
other countries are complete mess we're
helping the world get out of this um so
that so the party did has done very well
and the number of of uh people have
suffered has been remarkably small and
even if the numbers are
are not true multiplied by 10 it's still
highly impressive but as cindy says
micron's different eventually and this
is the other main point the the economic
costs are just going to come too great i
mean the costs of closing down these
cities the costs the opportunities cost
because
companies can't work
leading to unemployment all this i think
when eventually china has to open up
because it cannot continue in this this
closed way forever
then they're going to get casualties and
they're going to get hospitalizations
and of course health reform is one of
the reforms that's really lagging
and there's a grave risk that unless
their vaccines are far more effective
than ours
and i'll put in just about every single
arm because as cindy rightly said at the
start it's a big country there are 1.4
billion people
let's suppose that five percent of those
get
get covered you have a really big
problem and the health services will be
overwhelmed
and and where do the people turn their
anger there's only one because
one target because everything good comes
from the party but since everything
comes from the party so does everything
bad so i think they've got a real
problem there
so cindy do you think we could see this
indefinitely being the case the
zero-code policy has she as signaled
when they plan to you know loosen up
perhaps open up borders
so i think it was always the plan to
keep this policy for this year firstly
because of the winter olympics happening
this week but also because of the
october national people's congress where
xi jinping was meant to step down in a
former life of chinese politics but is
now going to be continuing his
governance you know it's the end of his
first decade in power but he abolished
term limits so that's a very politically
sensitive and important time in october
so they were never going to allow kobe
flair up before then anyway
we're now looking at 2023 before china
opens up but even then given what we've
talked about you know is not certain it
does seem like china's holding out for
its own homemade mrna vaccines or
homemade antiviral drug but you know
even if those things are highly
effective as effective as fizer even if
they come next year there will still be
some number of casualties some number of
infections some number of deaths and
until the government starts leading the
public conversation towards accepting
that's okay and rather than one case or
one death being a problem the goal posts
are just going to be way too high to me
for any realistic medical breakthroughs
to come in the near future so
they're really gambling at the moment
they're crossing their fingers and i
don't really think they know when
they're going to open up or how
charlie it's interesting you're talking
about the economy because in cindy's
piece she says that in the past year
china's economy grew by eight percent uh
which
is obviously striking if you compare it
to how other countries have fared during
the pandemic do you think we can take
that figure seriously and if so does
that suggest a zero covered policy it's
gonna be more uh of a problem for
countries that rely on china than china
itself
well i i don't take any of these gdp um
statistics seriously i mean i could we
could go out into the street and i'll
hear
outside the spectator dig a hole and
fill it in and it would count towards
the gdp
it's it's very much a question of your
productivity and for the chinese
communist party what really matters is
unemployment and i think cindy had a
figure in her piece again about uh four
million companies that have folded in
the last year so in eight percent
whatever i mean don't forget of course
that's coming from a low base but what
really matters is is the welfare of the
people the the feeling of prosperity
etc so um
and and you know cindy says well she
doesn't think that the country is going
to open until well we don't exactly know
when the party congress is going to be
but it'll be october or november um but
i'm not expecting it until the whole
process is finished which is the
national people's congress as opposed to
the party's congress uh and that will
take place in in march 2023 so i'm not
expecting anything uh before that and so
we've
probably got at least a year and i think
cindy was right to to indicate that it
may even be longer than that
where the economic
situation is going to deteriorate for a
number of reasons that are extraneous to
cover it also
but also but in particular because of
the um
the cavity situation where china has
been held up by exports its export
performance in in in the last year but
most analysts think that that won't
continue uh at the same level because of
course
we in the west have had a pretty bad
year
or two in the past and have had to
import a lot of stuff from china uh now
our economies as we've opened up are
beginning to get back onto our feet so
exports may drop
and that may affect employment and
that's the crucial issue the employment
issue
and charlie i just want to talk about
the piece you write for the magazine
this week where you challenge this
notion that uh you know the chinese
government isn't interested in the old
intelligent methods can you tell us why
well um i mean this was something put
out in in the in the times newspaper
leader and i don't know who writes those
leaders and what lots of experience they
have but it's it's the most
extraordinary statement uh i mean you
have to ask yourselves why in that case
does china have an enormous ministry of
state security uh the equivalent of our
secret intelligence service uh you have
to ask why richard moore the head of our
service said well uh china is our number
one priority and you have to ask
yourself other things like what on earth
are they doing
the brits doing expelling three uh
intelligence officers
as they did in 2020 um but i think the
point of the spectator piece is yes for
sure um
traditional espionage is not just alive
but you know on being conducted on a
massive scale and i didn't even go in
really into any detail on the cyber side
but beyond that because china is an
intelligent state in which
you could say that
information intelligence in in chinese i
think cindy will confirm ching ba is is
frankly there's no great difference uh
and and increasingly actually one could
say that open source intelligence is as
good as hidden intelligence um so it's
been collected in a whole manner of of
ways beyond just the traditional
espionage even though that remains a
really important um part of it
and i don't think that
we are yet
protecting ourselves sufficiently
against that sort of threat uh and i
think there's a lot more that will be
coming out about this in in
weeks to come
and you yourself have been tapped out
for once
yes um after i i left the the diplomatic
service and ceased to have a diplomatic
visa which may well actually be a
relevant uh consideration this is not
uncommon this happens on a frequent
basis to those who the chinese
intelligence services believe
either have historic knowledge or could
be of use and i was
advisor to the foreign affairs committee
of the house of commons
i think that would certainly
have made me a target plus the fact that
having having worked in the british
government for all those years and in
the european government
i know people i know a few things
why not have a crack at me they did
cindy just finally um is interesting
hearing charlie's experience because
obviously we recently had the
news stories about christina lee and her
influence in parliament so how common do
you think this is well i think charlie's
piece is really interesting because see
what he says is that these are called
iceberg operations where you know what
we see is just the tip basically and
it's interesting that mi5 did release
that because it's not very common
obviously in 2020 something similar
happened as charlie mentioned but it
does make you wonder what else is
happening underneath the surface now i
think it's important that charlie knows
how the chinese do these things because
he worked in china for so many decades
and because he worked in the british
government as well the question is if he
hadn't if people were there tapping up
don't have that experience don't have
that knowledge
do they know what to do when they are
potentially being scouted out when when
someone is asking them for coffee when
someone is asking them questions you
know what is the training there and i
think the important thing that charlie
mentions in his piece is that we need
more education we need academics to
understand better and businesses and
politicians to be better trained in
identifying this kind of approach um so
that you know i mean i think every
intelligence service is going to try to
do this to all countries in the world
that's what the intelligence service
does and i'd be quite worried if the
brits weren't trying similar things in
china but it's about knowing when that's
happening and being you know fully
transparent and mindful of it
thank you cindy thank you charlie
in his column for the magazine this week
douglas murray writes about why he
thinks social media posts by britain's
ambassador to ukraine represent the
weakness of our national character to
explain douglas joins me now
douglas in your column this week you
expressed your concern for our
ambassador in kiev
what's bothering you
well almost everything um our ambassador
uh from britain to the ukraine is one uh
melinda simmons
and uh she's obviously not a household
name in the uk
members of the diplomatic corps tend not
to be
i've taken an interest in her because of
course this is a very important time in
kiev and uh we have uh an ambassador
uh whose social media accounts at any
rate seem to suggest that she is the
absolutely prototypical example
of uh modern britishness
that is
she seems obsessed with uh um first of
all gender issues secondly to do with
mental wellness issues uh to do with the
importance of me time
and much more and i give examples in the
column of this and they are
of an asinine nature that is
i think quite extraordinary for anyone
who reads it
can you talk us through some of those
examples um douglas um you talk about um
her use of linkedin and also discussing
outfits that she's been wearing
yes that's right uh her instagram
account she a little while ago she she
she posted a photograph of herself with
a
a chaplain on one side and a member of
the armed forces on the other and she
said all three of the people in this uh
photograph are in their work dress uh
the army chaplains in his the military
guard is in his uh and i'm also in my
work dress now miss simmons's work dress
is a um rather charming uh dark blue top
with a pleasant light blue jacket and i
wouldn't draw that any attention to that
if she hadn't have done herself why did
she mention this because she says i am
the only one of these three people in my
uniform that does not have pockets and
uh
she seems to think this is some kind of
gender point i don't know i mean you
know better about this than me uh uh
katie but uh but i think it's possible
for women to buy clothes with pockets
and there's also of course that other
accessory that women have often used
some very famous women the handbag she
says it's not possible ms simmons our
ambassador in ukraine says that's not
possible because you have to rummage in
a handbag
she does have an every woman solution to
that which is that it turns out she has
a sort of valet who stands behind her uh
holding her essential items uh that's a
sort of normal twittering uh um
uh post by her others uh are not quite
so elevated i think we can say uh she
recently posted about the the
difficulties that can come from the
question of whether or not you should
drink a hot drink during interviews uh
now i don't know i'm i'm coping with one
at the moment
miss simmons says however that this is a
big problem she says the pitfalls of
drinking a hot drink doing an interview
are huge she says take a sip when it's
too hot and it's not a good look for
anyone spilling it on your outfit i
don't know i just managed uh dribbling
accidentally again i i don't think i did
but uh
she says these are all very difficult
things in answering a question she says
but on balance she's decided to drink
tea or coffee during an interview
because she says it can it can show
power it can show she's not phased
particularly she says in the face of
difficult questions which she says often
have a distinctly gendered tinge now who
could have expected that uh the the
character we now know miss simmons to be
would see a gendered tinge in anything
now of course again this is all the kind
of tittle tattle until you come to
events of recent days and there we can
find
our ambassador in ukraine
talking about uh the very very troubling
events going on on the borders of
ukraine the potentially imminent
invasion of that country by uh
the armed forces of vladimir putin
she says uh that she said she said
recently it is intense these days in
kiev intense there's a sort of lovely
teenagers and that
she says and it may well be for some
time to come of course the amassing of
130 000 troops on the borders of the
country you're in can do that to
somebody can't they um but she says that
nobody can keep going indefinitely on
adrenaline and nerves
and that's why she said she recently
grabbed a 30-minute walk in the snow and
came back feeling several kilos lighter
and she she accompanied this with the uh
hashtags hashtag decompression and
hashtag stress management uh the the the
long and the short of it is that
our ambassador's
uh social media accounts
all seem to suggest
uh that she is struggling
uh with the job she has
uh and that she says you know there
she's got finite resources uh finite
resources of resilience and she's very
close to burnout and it's it's it's why
she needs to do things like go and put
her feet on the ground
take a walk in the woods um i i think
this is totally totally unsuitable for a
person in such a serious position
and just finally douglas we're talking
about how the character of the nation is
perceived but
when we're talking about how
the uk is seen by the russians by the
ukrainians i wonder what you made of the
general government approach here because
um if you look at you know uk media
foreign media france and germany really
uh being written almost as the
bad guys the ones not showing enough
solidarity to ukraine and the uk and
summer camps coming out quite well for
that um do you see that
well
it's obviously the case there's a divide
within nato there's a divide within the
western alliance germany the totally
unreliable ally in relation to russia
because
germany uh we often talk about elite
capture of the chinese in uh uh the the
chinese communist party is made as an
elite capture
in the west in countries including
britain and and america but but elite
capture is something that the russians
have managed to do in germany uh to a
quite extraordinary degree germany is a
totally unreliable ally when it comes to
russia
and we probably have to accept that
whilst lamenting it and hopefully in
some way punishing germany for that
correcting them for it embarrassing them
for it um so yes there are there are
divides i'm not for war of course with
russia i simply think that if you um if
you're going to prop up an ally like
ukraine even in the relatively
minimalist way that we have uh you
should make sure
uh that you look like you're not
bluffing now it's possible that in the
days and weeks ahead uh our own country
and other allies who've supported the
ukrainians in recent weeks with lethal
and non-lethal uh weaponry uh will have
to make a decision they will have to
decide whether the bluff can work and
whether we can deter vladimir putin or
whether effectively he rolls in and we
have to scarpa pretty sharpish saying
i'm sorry it was a bluff all along
but that's why you need to look like
that's why these
presentation matters
it matters because it you need to look
like a serious power in order to counter
a serious power
and
and and this is why i lament this sort
of fracturing of
of our country and our reputation and
much more by having these sort of
incredibly low-grade gender-obsessed
me obsessed representatives in such a
serious place as kiev is at the moment
as for the wider picture i mean it's it
is really lamentable there was a press
conference i think yesterday in kiev and
uh in front of the ukrainian prime
minister and uh
the first question that came up from a
member of the british press corps was a
question
about uh
the precise timing and nature of the
cake
that boris johnson may or may not have
been given uh during his uh
birthday celebrations at some point
during one of the lockdowns um
i don't know i mean i along with the
sort of self-obsessed me time britain
we've also got to get used to the fact
that we have an incredibly frivolous
debate across much of british media
these days uh we have itv
correspondence tweeting out there was a
cake
as a sort of scoop revelation and much
more i lament what boris johnson and
some of his
mates and others have been doing in
downing street i think is itself a
letdown of the british people and the
trust we put in them but for god's sake
i mean we have 130 000 russian troops on
the ukrainian border it's possible that
if the russians invade ukraine the
chinese will see the green light to take
taiwan and the 21st century begins with
a land grab of two of the most hostile
and appalling powers on earth uh it's
possible that's all going on and wow
how the history books would
be amazed that at that very point
westminster and the british media was
obsessed with marzipan
thank you douglas
we're going to finish up in the states
vice president kamala harris's approval
ratings are lower than her last four
predecessors
what's gone wrong
on the spectator's website this week
freddie gray writes about the rumors
that joe biden might boot harris into
the vacancy at the supreme court
he joins me now alongside kate andrews
freddie on the spectator website this
week you write that kamala harris's days
as vice president could be numbered why
is that
well i'm not sure that they will be
numbered i think that the headline maybe
did a little bit more work that should
have done that
i mean there's certainly this wild idea
that's been flying around washington um
that kamala harris could be moved on to
the supreme court to make way for a new
uh a more popular vice presidential
figure who could take over from a sort
of failing joe biden
uh before the 2024 presidential election
as i say it's quite a wild idea and what
looks more likely what seems to be
happening is that camel harris is
actually involved in choosing very
heavily involved in choosing
the next supreme court nominee because
there is now a vacancy opening up in
june
but i think the very fact this rumor was
talked about and talked about so much
and by democrats as well as republicans
shows how much the democrats are
panicking they're in a real bind they
know that the midterm elections are
going to be bad or they fear that
they're going to be dreadful
and they know that the harris biden
administration sorry biden harris it was
called harris biden by biden once that's
quite a funny slip um is is a is a
disaster at the moment and it doesn't
seem to be showing any signs of
recovering so they're trying to find
another option and they're trying to
find another candidate another problem
is even if you got rid of harris who is
very unpopular more unpopular than biden
who would you find to replace her there
doesn't seem to be anyone
yes kate as freddie touches on in a way
the very fact this rumor seems to have
so much mileage points to issues with
kamala harris why is it that she is so
unpopular you uh wrote about her some
time ago warning of issues ahead
so as freddie mentioned katie kamala
harris is not doing very well in the
polls she has pulled well before uh but
at the moment her approval rating can be
anywhere between the mid 30s in that
percentage point and i think she's
actually hovering on average in in the
mid 40s with over 50 disapproval rating
one of the difficulties for harris is
that um this is a long-term trend so
when she was actually running for the
top job in the democratic primaries to
be the next president united states to
be their nominee she was pulling in the
single digits in 2020. she quite
cleverly removed herself backed out
before there were any votes so that this
could be you know an even more obvious
problem for her uh in the national media
and then allow people like elizabeth
warren to take the flack to not do as
well to see biden and even bernie
sanders for a while searching ahead and
she waited quite quietly in the wings
and then of course was appointed his vp
and and has had popular moments but
never really when she's put herself
center stage and
as i wrote for spectator world uh last
year i think one of the the many
problems that she's had is that
flip-flopping people don't quite know
where she stands and also when you dig
into her past the democratic party is
pretty uncomfortable with a lot of the
stances that she used to take i mean she
was very tough on crime when she was
attorney general of california now she's
soft on crime she's changed her opinions
on fracking on health care um as i wrote
in the piece at the time i think
she was very tough on crime happy to
praise and praise herself for sending
lots of low-level drug users to prison
but you know was very sympathetic while
doing so it doesn't quite gel especially
for where the democratic party is now
she has a lot of political skeletons in
her closet and i think that impacts on
her approval rating too so
understandably the democratic party is
getting a little bit nervous
if biden doesn't end up running for a
second term and that's still a big
question mark he is getting on we don't
know if it's something he's going to
want to do she would be the obvious
candidate the the establishment party
candidate to replace him but
given her issues with approval in the
past and certainly now she might not be
somebody that they actually want to have
go up against say a popular republican
and freddie if kamala were to go
and if we go along with that rumor for
now
who do democrats really think would fare
better
well the fantasy candidate
is michelle obama
americans like dynasties and they're
sort of drawn to them so this idea of
michelle obama kind of coming back and
and the obama's playing a sort of front
line role in politics has been very
attractive to a lot of democrats for a
while
there's been no indication that she
actually would do it uh and a lot of
people thought that biden should pick
her instead of kamila harris
but again she showed no sign that she
was interested in doing it the obamas of
course are making large sums of money
through spotify and netflix and i think
they might be enjoying that slightly
more than
uh
the the grubby politics of washington dc
at the moment
uh and you know the other candidates are
pete bootaj uh the transportation
secretary
uh but again he ran a presidential
campaign that sort of floundered
um amy klobuchar another presidential
candidate in 2020
uh again i'd say
her her candidacy had weaknesses so
there's no real good option apart from
the michelle obama one which would
definitely generate a lot of enthusiasm
among sort of democratic grassroots and
sort of bring the party back as a sense
of optimism
but
there's no evidence that there's that
that idea is based in reality
freddie howard team kamala coping um
because as kamala harris comes under
more pressure there's definitely um
reports that all is not well in the team
we're hearing about destructive work
patterns and perhaps kamala's own side
turning on her
well there's a lot of nasty whispers
about her and a lot of briefing against
her in in the washington press uh she
recently changed her team she jumped
some of her old advisors and tried to
sort of make over and got some hillary
clinton uh people involved which uh you
know given hillary clinton's popularity
is not necessarily a great idea um but
there are there are rumors and some
people look at the videos of her and
suggest that she's on drugs i don't
think there's any evidence to that or
that she's drinking heavily
i don't think there's any firm evidence
of that but she certainly doesn't seem
uh to be performing well i think she's
well aware of the fact that she's
unpopular uh and even a cold-hearted
person like me can feel a bad squeak of
sympathy for her at the moment because
she's struggling so much
and kate just finally if we're looking
at whether it's biden or kamala harris
going up who are the republican
contenders we should be looking out for
to be honest there are so many i mean
the big question within the republican
party right now is whether or not donald
trump would try to seek his second term
and that would just throw everything
into a a different direction because you
have people like ron desantis the
governor of florida he's made a lot of
waves during covet uh people like ted
cruz who are big supporters of the
president who also have presidential
ambitions who may step back or make
different choices if donald trump
decides to pursue it um but it's very
unlikely that donald trump wouldn't be
challenged and then you have big
question marks around some of those
rising stars in the party and
established stars people like the former
governor of uh south carolina nikki
haley also a former representative to
the u.n there's a real south carolina
contingent actually senator tim scott as
well has made a lot of waves i mean
these would be very difficult people
actually for kamala harris to go up
against uh in in a in a general election
um i think even for president biden
arguably maybe kamala's best shot would
be someone like president trump because
it would be quite divisive for lots of
different reasons um on on both sides
but the republican party has a lot to
grapple with before uh anyone's going to
know who biden or kamala harris are
running against the midterms however do
look to to be very favorable for the
republican party
so the internal politics are going to
matter just as much as the external ones
come november
thank you kate thank you freddie
that's it for this week once again a
special thank you to canaccord generity
wealth management for sponsoring the
week in 60 minutes
canaccord provide the expertise you need
to build your wealth of confidence
you can visit candywealth.com to find
out more
and if you enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon so you never miss an
episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you